[Music]
let's go out to amanda in new york city
what's up amanda
hi guys how are you thank you for taking
my call good how are
you i'm all right i'm looking for a
little bit of advice i think my
situation is a little unique but trying
to look for a little bit of color
um
so i work full-time at a law firm and my
boss was the idea of applying to law
school and um inheriting the firm in the
event that i was accepted
so i was recently accepted um and so now
i'm trying to deal with payment of
tuition i'm also fortunate in that my
boss is funding half of the tuition and
take my responsibility to fund the other
half
um my husband and i were in the middle
of baby step two when i got my
acceptance and so we paused the baby
steps to try to cash flow as much of law
school as we could
but we do still have some student loan
debt
from previous from my undergrad
and so i'm trying to deal with
the guilt of the possibility of having
to take on
additional student loan debt
while also still trying to balance what
seems like
a really great opportunity
i don't think those things are mutually
exclusive
okay it is a great opportunity it's
pretty cool
your boss clearly sees something in you
and is willing to put um his
money where his mouth is right
right there's very few things more
flattering than that i think somebody
telling you uh uh you're my person and
i'll spend the rest of my life with you
is is really flattering
and a boss that calls you in and says i
see so much in you and should go get
extra training and i'm willing to to
foot part of that bill that's awesome
and right i was a dean of students at a
law school for for
a long time
and the law school debt is crippling
and the panic and the anxiety and the
frustration and the movements
professionally that happens
makes me tell you do not go into debt
and it can still be a great opportunity
and not the right time for this great
opportunity
and if your boss says it's now or never
then he's giving you a hint into his
character in a way that you may not want
to tether yourself to him for the next
four five ten years
if he says absolutely understand
um
struggle back to me and you and your
husband get really intense and save up
the cash because i think the
uh a law degree is one of the single
greatest credentials you can have i
think it's a super valuable thing and
i'm in awe of people who go through that
process
um i just wouldn't borrow money to do it
and i know that's hard what i'm saying i
know that
yeah it's definitely like a hard pull to
tell only because my husband and i are
in our 30s so i'm going back like a
little bit later in general and so how
much longer do you have left amanda i
shouldn't started yet i haven't started
no you haven't oh i think she's in the
moment i'm sorry here's here's what i
know i'm supposed to be starting in
august did you get into an ivy league
school
no okay i'm going to a local school it
is private i was given um a partial uh
scholarship so the entirety of the bill
between the two of us is thirty thousand
he's paying for half of that and i would
be responsible for fifteen my husband
and i after buckling down cash flowed
like or squeezed out enough cash flow
half of that and so i would
hypothetically be taking out a loan for
the balance yeah i i wouldn't
i just wouldn't do that i'd rather say
one go in and defer your admission which
i don't outside of an ivy league school
that's just gotten incredible admissions
pressure
i don't know a law school that wouldn't
defer in this current climate
the the tables have turned at most law
schools where they're looking for
students when i was trying to go to law
school back in the day i was thinking
about it
it was very very few seats and a lot of
students and that's flipped and so you
can go defer your admission for one year
and tell your boss man i'm all in i love
this idea it's just not financially
feasible for us my guess is he's going
to say what's it going to cost
and if you've got some skin in the game
he may meet that otherwise he may say
cool and say we're going to make this
work in the fall my husband are going to
save up a bunch of money and we're going
to go forward with it and if he asks you
you can say we just don't do debt in our
house
and if he's got a visceral response
that's negative to that i think that
gives you a long-term picture of who
you're working for quite honestly who's
gonna and it's just he's looking at one
of your values and saying oh that's
stupid i'm like and i just don't know if
he's gonna do that i don't think he's
going to go i don't think he's going to
i think he values you a lot
and amanda do you um
how does that hit you though waiting a
year just say all of that worked out
right you're able to defer
save up the money and have it
to go in a year what is that what does
that do to you
i just don't know if
within a year you would be able to save
that amount of money because over the
course of i'm doing a part-time program
because i would be working
full-time as and going to school
part-time and so it's four years versus
three
um and i just can't be like saving
what would be forty thousand dollars in
a year yeah but after that i mean you're
talking about raises you're talking
about externships where you're going to
get paid you mean there's all different
ways especially once you get out of your
1l year there's ways to get part-time
job i mean there's ways to make this
work
with additional resources you're really
struggling to get through the first year
and a half if not two years and then
after that the the game changes quite a
bit
uh how how old are you
we're 32. that's the other that's the
other addition so i i told this story in
in um my latest book here my wife was
talking to a couple of friends who were
um i think they were 35.
and both of them they're all hanging out
and one of them said you know what like
i really kicked myself cause i should
have gone to law i mean to med school
and um this person's spouse said me too
like that's my dream to always go to med
school but we're 35 and we won't be
actually out practicing medicine
on our own until we're 42
and my wife who's very very wise said
that's not the question
the question is uh or you're going to be
42.
the question is do you want to be
doctors when you're 42 or not
so i would tell you is you're going to
be 36 you're going to be 37
do you want to be a lawyer when you're
37 or not a lawyer when you're 37 that's
the real question and if you want to be
a lawyer when you're 37 take a year work
like crazy have your husband pick up a
second job because this is a family
shift and you know as well as i do law
school's really hard on everybody right
so that when i'm 37 i'm gonna take the
back two-thirds of my life and be an
attorney and go help the least of these
or do whatever we're doing with our law
firm does that make sense
yeah it's real real easy
it is it's so hard it's so so hard
especially when it feels like i've got a
deal that i've got to move on right this
second or it all comes down yeah if
you're backed into a corner that way i'd
let the deal pass that's it you all you
never make really good decisions when
you don't have a lot of options and it's
like it's either now or never
you're gonna make bad decisions on that
that's right yeah so just like take a
breath and
and and i think it's going to be okay i
mean i think i think it's going to force
you to ask different questions and to
maybe engage in conversations that are
uncomfortable but it's worth it to do it
so that you don't tackle you don't put
all this debt on you guys here in the
next few months that's exactly right i
think you're gonna end up in law school
you're gonna do great things and you're
not gonna owe anybody anything we'll be
right back